the weather might be getting colder in  your part of the world but that doesn't  mean you have to stop playing pokemon go  I'm Tony and this is your seasonal  gamespot news update Pokemon go is  getting its first in-game event in  celebration of Halloween during this  time you'll encounter spooky pokemon  like gastly Haunter and Gengar more  often you'll also earn six candies for  every Pokemon you catch which is twice  the normal amount and you'll get a  second candy for every Pokemon you  transfer to the professor Pokemon goes  Halloween event runs from October 26  through November first and that's not  the only game celebrating the holiday  overwatch has a special brawl and  halloween items available now and  Destiny's festival of the Lost kicks off  on october 25th head over to gamespot  for a full list of all the halloween  themed events going on and for all the  biggest game news you're already in the  right place  you